this is 8 news now live at noon live
local now
one final patrol to the end of his watch
metro police detective justin terry
carried through las vegas to his funeral
after losing his life in the line of
duty thank you for joining us this
afternoon i'm john langler more than a
week ago detective justin terry was on
the clock he was driving on u.s 95 near
the centennial bowl when fate stepped in
today he's being remembered at a funeral
in henderson with the focus on his life
not his tragic death christian cousins
live in henderson where the memorial is
wrapping up christian
well john good afternoon well the hour
and a half service just wrapped up here
inside the central church in henderson
where i can tell you that family and
close friends gathered for a very
intimate service for the officer now
take a look here at some of the video
that was shot inside the church now
those who knew detective justin terry
say the 45 year old officer touched so
many lives and was a remarkable human
being detective terry was a veteran
officer with more than 20 years of
service protecting vulnerable children
as he was assigned to the sex crimes
bureau and the sexual assault and abuse
section many officers shared memories
today the majority were not police
related they said detective terry loved
the outdoors and a true inspiration for
the entire department but it was his
family that had these words to share
there is always the chance that you may
never see them walk through that door
again
we knew he loved us and that he was
proud of us
and we were of him as well
because we said it
nothing was left on his head
i will not miss anything more than those
big strong hugs that he gave when i said
well detective terry passed away on june
10th when the seal beam fell on his
unmarked police vehicle on u.s 95 now we
can tell you that many officers from
metro police and other agencies like
nevada highway patrol and county
sheriff's office from around the state
were here in support including las vegas
mayor carolyn goodman back out here live
the officer's family said he was their
everything he said that he was a role
model a protector and will truly be
missed by everyone here in the las vegas
valley christian council is live local
now
christian thank you very much resorts
world also honored detective terry today
as that procession was driving through
the valley you can see the big sign on
the led wall paying tribute to detective
terry's life and his work
in other news